c'est incontestablement le produit
d'appel de cette édition jo wilfried
tsonga est là pour attirer les
spectateurs dans le palais des sports
jamais l'open d'orléans n'avait
accueilli un joueur de ce calibre
les organisateurs vont donc tout faire
pour qu'il soit placé dans les
meilleures conditions
ce qui veut dire s'adapter aux exigences
et besoins des joueurs qui vise très
haut niveau c'est très simple il m'a
demandé de mettre une table de massage
dans sa chambre pour que dès qu'il a
fini ses entraînements décline ses
matchs il a son propre kiné ce qui n'est
pas le cas de tous les joueurs vous en
doutez bien
et donc ils sont propres qui n'est pour
être tranquille pouvoir pouvoir bien
travailler avec son kiné il veut être au
calme dans sa chambre donc ça réunit on
lui livre une table de kiné pour user en
plus des efforts nécessaires à l'accueil
d'une star le tournoi est aussi obligé
cette année à cause d'une évolution du
règlement international d'accueillir 48
jours de simples contre 32 auparavant
il a donc dû créer un deuxième site de
compétition en banlieue à saran qui
n'accueillait que quelques matchs les
années précédentes
cette année on a aujourd'hui lundi 23 77
matchs de simple près des sports et sept
matchs de simple au cjf de floraison
vrai c'est qu'il a fallu construire un
autre village au club de tennis
il a fallu au 8 août une équipe des
ramasseurs de balle des juges de ligne
mais parquet pour quelques heures pour
du lundi au jeudi
donc en fait qu'on a on a deux sites
séparés 10 km l'accès à ce site est
gratuit pour les habitants de fleury les
aubrais tarif réduit pour les autres et
les joueurs de clubs qui tape la balle
sur ce court habituellement auront le
plaisir de se dire que des joueurs
professionnels sont passés par là